this show is brought you by the cash for
the cash app it shows my do you think
they're gonna love that the number one
finance app in the App Store cash app is
the simplest way to send or receive
money especially when your friends o you
or when yell them oh when do you use the
cash app you're obsessed with this I
love you cash I have I say my friends
money all the time I use this yeah like
if I owe them no embarrassing I didn't
I'm not doing that so don't think I have
I used the cash cart a lot I use the
cash card at Starbucks I using a Whole
Foods when we go
I love that thing love it easiest way to
try and grow your money you know that
mm-hmm growing money every day yeah tell
us about it Kashyap is also the easiest
way for you to grow your money as we
said in the stock market with their
investing features with the cash app you
can instantly invest in any stock for as
little as one dollar but there was an
exclamation point out at least one
dollar which is all I have you guys got
it and I need the stock money did you
know the brokerage services are provided
by cash app investing a subsidiary of
square and a member of si PC side PC
well now you do and as always when you
sign it from the cash app or use the
promo code Whitney not only will you
instantly received $10 but cash app will
also donate $10 for The Trevor Project
why an amazing organization that
provides protective services to LGBTQ
youth across America don't forget promo
code Whitney when you download cash app
from the App Store today
I cannot believe you have not
complimented me in my haircut I have
wear twice wait you sent it I sent a
message and I said then I said very chic
and you said much better
I've been are dams I'm just call me
Karen from now on I think I think you're
like a very chic
I get the powerpuff girl butter crowd
grew up and she was a woman I didn't
hear anything you just said
did anyone make out anything he just
said the patterns a woman what do you
want to have a cup of coffee and circle
back in here I can't have enough you
have okay we're both setting an
intention on this bag I guess we're both
gonna start talking she gets too excited
to tell you that I thought that I could
this is a we speak for a living yeah at
some point we have to learn how to
conjugate our works because we host a
podcast Benton you bendin showed up
wearing a diamond ring and I just
graduation ring that is so pretty it has
my class engraved and cuz I don't want
one you couldn't wear it suppose my
grandma's diamonds diamond ring you've
watched when I'm married it's the wrong
finger I'm like okay okay so let's start
that over
give me another compliment about my hair
I was Sanibel that you get intelligible
like Powerpuff Girl buttercup if she was
a grown up woman don't know who that now
that you've said it I now I very great
man
now that I can hear you I don't
understand you but thank you she's an
icon legend stoner well they're very
thrown off about my haircut I went to
the Comedy Store last night in the
comments were like did you get a
facelift I saw yesterday like I love
that you can't figure out what about me
is different comedians I see every
single night Neal Brennan was like you
look so what did you do what did you do
to your face I'm like I cut 9 inches off
my hair how could you not do you feel
better I feel so much better because I
mean you saw me I was curling dead bales
of hay every I mean
but I mean it looks it makes you look
like even younger frosh that's not very
French cover a Parisian no very French I
I really want to talk about the flu
because everyone's got it everyone's
sick and they'll let you know people
will let you know when they're sick
there's this there's like an apocalyptic
flu going around where people are out
for like ten days if you get the flu
shot I well the flu shot is only thirty
percent effective I was reading and so I
don't do it just cuz you know me I don't
have time to do anything so I don't make
time for I don't really I don't get sick
because I don't I don't mess with people
when they're sick I don't like when
people come to work when they're sick
and they're like I'm sick just don't
don't touch me just I'm like me touching
you isn't what's gonna get me sick
you're here right if I can hear you say
don't hug me I've already got your
effluvium of germs go home typhoid mary
go home if you're sick
no one is gonna give you a prize for
showing that's the thing they want to be
like but I showed up I hand if I wasn't
here who would who would who would
handle the party what would happen like
it's my birthday you're a guest half the
holiday parties I went to people were
like oh don't get near me I'm sick why
are you here no wouldn't wanna go back
to Ground Zero your house I don't like
it when people come to work like nobody
respects you more because you showed up
because you were sick no one's like oh
my god did you see Jenni
she like has the flu and she's here
today isn't that cool
yeah you're like no nurse Amazon a side
effect of the bird flu also don't get
other people sick it's rude I was at the
Comedy Store a couple nights ago a
comedian brought wet ones on stage the
low wet wipes started wiping down the
microphone that's not gonna help anyone
it's it's because there's um what's a
call there's this punch
there's a spongy part underneath you
know what it's just it's so real I've
seen a comment to can sanitize ER and
squirt it on the mic no that's just
insane this is rude I was gonna break
them up I was gonna say wild but I don't
want to say wild anymore I'm not gonna
say wild anymore I'm not gonna say like
anymore and I'm not gonna do this with
my mouth guys this is the silent but I'm
really gonna try to not be
so shrill what I'm talking and I'm gonna
try to talk slower this I think is about
the pace I should be talking about I
normally gotta like talk like this and
I'm like cutting everybody off and I'm I
cut myself off I get so bored of hearing
myself talk that sometimes I was
listening back to one episode and I
literally interrupted myself like
anyways ihara have you ever heard that
thing for people that talk fast they say
if you think you're talking slow talk
slower yeah I mean that's in stand-up we
say that if you think that you're
talking yeah my speech therapist tell me
that but cool yeah yeah and if you're
bombing always talk slower on stage yeah
for sure okay well we're not really
covering anything so far I got a message
from somebody who was really upset that
our podcasts didn't have a theme they
were like bill birnes podcast has a
theme it's a weekly diary the weekly
bi-weekly diary we understand the theme
of this podcast and Tom Segura and
Cristina's podcast they try to scare
their guests we don't know what your
theme is and I was like I don't I didn't
know we had to have a theme that's what
I'm doing a podcast is we weren't
supposed to be organized and then so I
posted on Instagram like what do you
guys think the theme is and I got a lot
of really funny mo I wanna know this
funny responses you guys wrote the theme
of your podcast random shit people need
to know being blessed and highly favored
why does it need a theme it's a fun
entertaining listen this is bragging
someone wrote chaos someone wrote like
gender-neutral your podcast theme
neutral someone wrote pure unfocused
awesomeness unfocused
and someone just wrote what are we gonna
do about the sand someone wrote art and
horses another one a potpourri of topics
and a lot of beating yourself up over
silly things I like a potpourri of
topics someone wrote unpopular opinions
goofy times and then someone wrote rad
bitch just talks about thanks so
unpopular opinions is a really good
basically so I don't
think we have a theme yet we'll get
there at some point I didn't realize
this podcast was so hard to explain to
other people but I will work on things
being a little more focused good for you
yeah that's the idea isn't it before I
introduce our guests I want to remind
everyone you can buy tickets to the tour
it's called the how dare you tour you'll
know this by now Whitney Cummings calm
you can see if we're coming to your city
stop asking me if I'm coming to your
city there's a very easy way to is know
crazy where people would rather just
comment under it but are you coming to
Tampa but why not this place but you can
get the answer that real quick I think
people forgot about websites yeah people
use the internet they Instagram is
Google you just want me to personally
answer your question even though you
could solve it real quick Whitney
Cummings calm we're also working on
merchandise it's coming down the PIA
very exciting Benton is over and if the
real it about this it looks so cool I
finally figured out a way to make bettin
happy just get them hoodies I love a
hoodie it's a how dare you on it yeah
they're really good I think they're
great art don't you like I've never seen
you this excited about anything because
I love fashion art and design I think
the most heated disagreement we've ever
gotten into was over maroon hoodies yes
for sure
I mean Benton pushed back hard on that
yes I thought we needed them yeah and
you you you but gave in I just like
black hoodies we got it what about black
thanks very simple I don't like extra
and you like things to be very extra I
know really my mother you're very gaudy
bent and I'm not God you're wearing a
diamond ring yes right now well you know
sometimes you gotta you gotta you got a
stun on them you're wearing a ring with
seven diamonds on it yeah with your name
engraved in it and a pink hat and a
denim jacket with fake holes
I bought these all they're mine it's
very good murse you're gonna love it yes
so a merch is coming down the pike I'm
just trying to hike please don't let me
say coming down the pike what else you
want to say what's your other hot topic
on that our guest for today is one of my
favorite people on the planet his name
is Andrew Schultz its Schultz right I'm
saying yes he's an angel person
literally one of my best friends and
he is actually why I started a podcast I
was going through a lot of heartbreak
with television I made two separate
pilots that were all like set to go and
really freak things happens like the
head of the network left or things
happen that I'm not allowed to talk
about or else I'd get sued and he kept
just going like why are you doing these
TV shows just do a podcast like just and
he's who kind of forced me to do it
and we met because he auditioned for an
HBO show that I did it was a pilot and I
was casting my boyfriend in the show and
it's actually really hard to cast your
boyfriend because you don't want to cast
someone too handsome because you don't
want to look like a narcissist
like I don't people being like why does
what anything she can get him that's why
you know like the first show I did I
cast Chris D'Elia because he was ugly
and it made me look like I wasn't
shallow you know like I just was like
I'll cast afore you know because I'm
humble very smart you know I'm not
obsessed with look so then after I could
not cast a boyfriend after Chris for
some reason it was just like it was so
hard and Andrew came in audition nailed
it nailed it he was so funny but I was
too insecure because I thought he was
too hot for me
and I thought that people were gonna be
like you're such an asshole that you
think that you would get that guy why I
mean you can't Chris he's a teenage
heartthrob just go to another teenage
heart throw it really s don't really are
I you know I didn't and then I ended up
hiring him to be in a movie that I made
the female brain movie and he had a
scene with Blake Griffin that is tested
the highest it was like everybody's
favorite scene in a movie he's so funny
he has lots of specials on YouTube the
views from the cysts and the crowd he
does especially entirely crowd work he
has a podcast called brilliant idiots
which is really funny I love Andrew we
we fight a lot we bicker a lot but he's
always the first person that I call if I
need advice great he came to Nashville
took us all out for drinks like he was
like he's the most fun down-to-earth to
like have full conversation with you
he's great yeah he's really provocative
and his stand-up and I appreciate that
right now especially since comedians are
all walking on eggshells and feel like
they can't make certain jokes not Andrew
yeah no Andrew Andrew is smart and he
expects you to be smart too together
that's correct that's correct and so our
word of the day I figured we would
choose one that would actually relate to
the podcast because the first 10 minutes
Andrew is really disoriented by where I
live because I moved
was shot I moved out to the woods as
everybody knows I shoot my podcast out
of my house behind me is literal
mountains and he's from New York so he
like had no idea what was going on and
we went on on my deck and I was like oh
yeah I live you know I have a holler do
you know what a Halloran yeah I know
what a holler is I want a holler so a
hallo
that is our word of the day it's an
elongated low land between ranges of
mountains hills or other uplands a
depression or hallo resembles a valley
I thought everyone knew what a hollow
was like me too I mean I've never come
in contact on who didn't but also so
confusing because if I'm from Virginia
West Virginia we call it a holler
we call a holler - I didn't know that it
was called a hollow that's spooky the
play didn't know that that's totally
creepy like that's the lesson demon shit
right there
but how holler is a derivative of a
hollow so which I just learned today
that was you told me today and I won't
be hollow is it TV show it's about done
by that with anybody on shock when they
found out sleepy I think we should do
the southern version called Sleepy
Hollow Sleepy Hollow
so that is our word of the day hollow
aka holler aka
watch Andrew go into a complete spiral
trying to understand it's good time what
that meant will you do your little
holler song you just made up oh yeah
stumble out of Bain and I don't look to
the holler that's all I got from it but
I hope you enjoyed it
Andrew Schulte Ria's
why why don't use headphones um yeah I
just don't like them and I don't like
hearing you that close oh yeah over here
all right that was one of the only
Instagram videos I clicked on for sound
when you and Dave Grohl we're doing that
what is it ASMR uh what does that stand
for audio sensory meridian response okay
come through got them
what up vented so um yeah I just don't
do the headphones it just is
uncomfortable it's unnecessary I know
how to talk in a microphone shouldn't do
headphones either it's great what do you
think will happen I think here's what I
think think you'll stop talking to me
it's like a psychological thing it's a
Pavlovian response of just like we're
podcasting and I also mind you've never
played before you don't have a Pavlovian
reaction they'll just say psychological
shit and then people believe you
actually made the female brain she knows
about this I've earned the right to be
completely full of shit okay see how it
goes just take them off let's just see
it I know but I guys have a different
I'm gonna look I I wasn't prepared to
not have them I now do my hair based on
like the heavens yeah interesting like I
would have put more work into this yeah
your hair looks totally different now I
can't even write what style is this what
is this what's going on I just feel it
makes me feel like everything's working
now I get now I see you know I mean like
how it shapes your face yeah yeah see
it's like well now I'm gonna keep it's
like a Jew without a yarmulke you know
this is like yeah I think I think we
should do a little time without the
headphones just right now it feels yeah
it makes me feel like things aren't
working good really
yeah let's just try it it makes me think
like that it you know what it here's
what it does okay
I think it makes me yell yeah when I
don't have them on because I'm doing
stand-up good like this is how I talk in
a microphone yes when I'm and I am
trying to not like oh no because it's
podcast it's worked so far has it we're
here you have me in a house in a robot
what did you call it a Wallach a holler
I don't know what that what it is you
don't even have internet here like
humans haven't gotten here company I
couldn't call you to say let me in
because I didn't have service that's how
much we shouldn't be here and then
you're like this is why I got this place
and then you open up the door to your
bedroom and like this is a Wallach this
is this is a holler that you knew I
wouldn't know what it was because you
really emphasize the word right like
like if you thought I knew it was you a
holler you know like ated like I'm a
land baron I'm not sure yes but Brogan
it's in like a town that's right even a
street you get here's the code for gate
one - you've a gated community inside
again distrust
do you have that you would even trust
the people within your gate people want
to kill me is that right
why it's fascinating I mean what the
security person said was why do they
want to could it's fascinating
I'm fascinated by the type of people who
would put death threats on me like you
would go to jail like you want to kill
me so bad that you would go to jail
forever so I wouldn't be around yeah and
the irony is I'm like you know if you
killed me I'd be everywhere like I'm not
that famous if you killed me I would be
so famous just in jail every day asking
wait it's a girl with the robot he's
gotta live with the robot I do I was
gonna make a will recently and I was
trying to figure out who to bequeath the
robot together why we all gotta have a
will why it's really if you have animals
huh mister I have animals okay yeah if I
die who takes the animals yeah I mean I
think we know is good yeah I know Benson
is gonna to know for real you got that
you got a you got a wall except he came
is this not convenient he came in right
as I was so sick he when we were touring
I had bronchitis so bad oh my god I
could hardly speak and death threats
started coming and then he's in my house
as just as someone's trying to kill me
and my immune system is shot and then
all of a sudden here is Benton just
worming his way in now you trust him
yeah I don't know my address do you do i
but really what I have it
oh no I'm telling yours oh yeah there I
don't know where we are
Benton said make a right at the Wallach
and then you just go right down that
Street I know what he's doing he
infantilizing me he's doing things so
that I can't do them myself if Benton
went out of town for a week I would
starve to death
Oh everything I do for you ask isn't I
kind of make things up to do no I think
you've brainwashed me but so people
death threats say again you had a
thought I was looking at your Instagram
I've had a lot of death threats a lot of
them yeah I get a lot of death how does
that manifest Erb I don't know they just
do it you know they're really they're
really passionate about something here's
what I was gonna say what is fascinating
is the security person said anyone who's
gonna try to kill you is not gonna give
you a heads-up ooh
that someone who really wants to kill
you I know it makes you ache just for a
whole other reason but whoever's gonna
kill you is not gonna give you a warning
yeah or put it in writing yeah sorry oh
those are usually not the ones to worry
about yeah I don't really worry about
the death threats that much I know they
seem so silly to me I mean do you really
think someone gonna kill you no I mean
someone sugar doesn't really love you I
know that so it's got to love you you've
gotta like break you yeah right you've
got to take away everything mm-hmm you
know maybe there's someone obsessed yeah
like do you get obsessive do guys obsess
do you have fans that are like mail that
obsess I a little bit but it's it's more
it becomes evident and I can talk about
this to my shows why look because the
security people like they think you're
talking about them when you talk about
this stuff and it's a form of
communication
so let's communicate with them hmm do
they send you pictures of their body no
but I do get lots of pictures and lots
of men's bodies and I make Benton look
at them and times up on me are they hard
guys saying hard or soft uh usually hard
don't make you write okay I I'm hoarding
dick pics they're so entertaining to me
I think hard normally right yeah you got
seven today so you're looking in the DMS
you look through this Benton looks
through them and the ones that are funny
I just have them show me but I'll look
through the DM sometime and how are they
funny the drawing thing I just think
they're funny to me cuz I'm just always
fascinated by like putting like
miniature alcohol bottles near like
they'd put things next to their dicks to
make it look bigger and I'm guys to me
I'd like that I think it's clever I
think it's interesting I like putting
the thought process together behind the
photos so it's a clever dick pick your
reward creativity or a reward humor a
reward creativity humor or complete
oblivion completely someone who has like
no idea what they're doing like there
was a guy that had a ramen cup of
noodles he knew what he was doing do you
think I think so wait to scribe it I'll
tell you ah it was this guy and he was
it was a very small man he was standing
up in his mirror on his bedroom and his
dresser there was a cup of shrimp ramen
instant noodles right by his penis right
by it so you think he was trying to make
his penis look bigger by putting an
object next to it
I find that a lot so weird object maybe
yeah because that's a really big people
do that but that was
like he was eating it I think he was
eating ramen noodles set it down and
took this pic to send you I'm obsessed
with the background obsessed with the
decor do you send dick pics cuz I'm I've
never should never sent one not even to
my girlfriend you know Jim Jefferies
actually made a really good point about
when he first started sending dick pics
it was back in the day when you would
set a picture your dick so they'd send a
picture of your tits like it was a
collateral thing it was a bargaining
chip that's right it was a like you have
some on me so I'm not gonna show anyone
this right so I think that's kind of the
only reason a guy would really send it
right yeah it was like mutual assured
you have to worry about this right I
have a picture of me naked but then I
think it became so normal and
commonplace for women to have naked
pictures no it's not really that even
right right like you shared your own
naked pictures mhm
remember that did I do I remember it
really yeah I didn't look at it really I
did such a bad photo it's it's I
although there was one was good when I
was looked like I was having a home
birth in the tub wait a minute there's
the choice no I'm like hunched over in
the tub oh I can reach my vagina I don't
need a brush with a handle on it
oh there you clean it I I'm always like
I'll be in the shower with my god oh and
then like yeah it she'll like you know
soap up and then I guess kind of like
rubbish she's not gonna do that in front
of you the way she cleans it when you're
not around I think is probably different
is it what is it you go in there I know
what I do yes I have a no-no douches no
good it messes up your pH it causes all
sorts of problems that you don't want to
know about right it no good that's like
an oil what is your pH like like an 8 or
9 I don't I don't know it's i7 I'm not
sure with the pH scale I don't know but
what happens is when your pH is off you
get like a UTI as you get yeast
infections like there's certain bacteria
again about a 7 or a thank you what did
you look at Madeline Gordo is really
don't allow for a lot of oxygen
interchange I mean it hurts
okay things are getting very swampy in
here I don't know it's just like a
little marsh it is like these are I
don't know what I don't know why I
thought this was a cute idea dude you
know what made me laugh so hard and why
watch all these clips I watch all the
clip I love that you're doing a podcast
really because I've been trying to I
wanted you to do the podcast and forever
I feel like I've been like begging you
to do this kind of things yeah and very
big part of why I do this what makes me
happy you and Rogan but um give you a
cut no I don't want anything from you
nothing but your friendship that is all
we are good friend and directions home I
went over to Wallach and then over I saw
the giraffe from that farm that sure
always that I was like what where am i
where am i that giraffe or do they just
replace it um no they they can't move
that thing don't they've had with it
just like Michael Jackson's chimps they
do what they would do there were three
of them
they had three there yeah yeah because
chimps don't walk around in tuxedos they
rip your face off
they yeah yes so any chimpanzee that you
see in an outfit at a birthday party
this is one that's being abused they put
it in a cage so that he can't develop
muscles oh yeah they keep it in a cage
where they can't move at all so the
muscles atrophy they're on tons of drugs
yeah and there were three of Michael
Jackson's chubbs as well this guy Bob
done fuck you Bob
that is the trainer who got them all the
animals and they had to substitute new
ones in because a grown chimp is gonna
kill someone you love these animals I
figured out why you love animals oh I
think I know what you're gonna say you
like distraction like we all like
distraction and you're very good at
solving problems you want to write a
script you can fucking do it right you
want to write a movie you can do it so
you need a distraction or a problem that
you cannot complete in your lifetime
that can never solve which is saving all
the animal huh it's actually a really
brilliant way of going through life yeah
you create
interest that you can never finish
therefore you're always distracted yeah
something to do
yeah I would say I agree with your logic
in a lot of ways the problem is it's so
awful and painful yeah it's not let me
let go
let's have that there's no but we do
have to finish because there are people
listening going how do you wash a vagina
and we have to get back to that well a
lot of people I know that put it into
the animals as well how do you watch
that it's called ashy you get on some
high heels you get on your tippy toes
and you get to work and did you just
fucking what does that highlight it I
like what's highlight oh you haven't
seen that no I've never heard of that
before
it's a great rap I think you would be a
highlight glove can you bring up a
highlight yeah on this TV is that like
that
what's that I'm obsessed with things
that don't have a name like you know the
thing that we grew up with it has an
apology's look at that that's how you
clean it you're right yeah but if you
just scoop that out get that pH down to
a four what is the thing called with
remember it was like a ping-pong paddle
and then a ball and you would things
that don't have names but we all use
toys beckham it was like a ball baby
paddle ball a paddle ball cat of all I
don't think that's what it's called is a
sport it's so mad at me appended it like
that after that phone rang your tune
changed okay the way you watch at least
I yes
then I want to get back to the end I
need it which ones we can look I know
this is I think that's a good idea
so there's a Amit that you can get that
is like an exfoliator met their Korean
and are you liking appengine I don't
know if you can get that yes because he
knows names of shit that I don't always
know the name of he worked at the mall
he worked at Sephora he knows all this
shit and it's like a mitt and exfoliator
glove and you can just get in the
crevices and your tush and your all of
that okay the whole system you gotta get
you got to get into those crevices you
got to get in there because otherwise
what it's good little fool shit just can
get wharf ii like the pier just yeah
like a war like you
look at some crab brush you got it yeah
you got a sale point I'm just it can get
bovine down there you want to just this
is really crazy
you've gotta beYOU got but I don't under
your armpits you gotta exfoliate you got
a scrub because smell comes from
bacteria yeah gotta scrub it okay yeah
so she probably vagina
you got a rent around it okay I mean you
put the glove on and you kind of just
but you don't go inside of it no no no
no never touch the inside of it
I don't think so when you clean it no no
how so how often you guys our together
that I don't like showering with only if
we have sex on her period and then it
has to go just full Carrie
yeah full Carrie go Carrie what is that
the movie Carrie go and just mutually
just kind of pull it together I'm glad
I'm glad that that's not a problem for
you a lot of guys are not curious not at
all of it yeah you know but she needs
sex how long have you been together like
eight months will you talk about it or
no you don't have to read about how did
you mean because one of the main
sessions really yeah she's living a DM
no way and then what about her made you
want to meet her she was attractive and
then what about you on the first date
made you want to see her again
she was smart mm-hmm and she was she was
like driven she's like has a real job
she's like a real person
a private Instagram thank God Oh hold me
she deletes Instagram like when she's
too distracted by it and like more and
more things were like good for her yeah
cuz healthy thoughts I want I didn't
want like a girl who like really want to
be like an Instagram celebrity years huh
like that cuz then it's all it's just
this weird tag me in that all this kind
of stuff and that was like the last
thing that she wanted I heard that girls
are asking guys on first dates to take
photos can you get can you just get me
real quick or of the food I remember I
flew a girl into to New York and she was
like taking pictures so he's taking
pictures like I'm in New York for
Instagram like as if she was traveling
and she was she was being trafficked she
was there to see right
but it was weird as if she was like
getting paid to pose like the
influencing it's like no I paid for your
flight exactly time here I'm your boss
you know me no I mean no you know this
is not a paid partnerships I am your
partner hashtag and this is the hashtag
I own you this weekend I don't own you I
know it's you but there's an expectation
right like if you flew a guy out uh-huh
there'd be an expectation to stay in a
hotel to stay in hotel not like there's
any near this place in Los Angeles
we're in basically down to my phone yup
yeah and there were cacti kapenga you've
heard of Topanga Johnny we're like it in
New York I don't know what to pay Meets
World
what's a quantum Estill ake Topanga
Canyon in New York like upstate New York
like Rai pick it see I live in the Kip C
of LA I don't know if you want to say
that yeah that you've gone downhill
things it's not going well okay so I'm
fascinated by this because last time we
were like I was really able to see you
were hanging out you were dating you
lived in Los Angeles whatever back in LA
the glory days
I'm fascinating you because you're so
you're so clear about things and you
have no blinders on and you don't delude
yourself this is something I love about
you so I always like to talk about red
flags like what are red flags were when
you meet a girl taking pictures or your
food asking someone on a first date you
want shallow out of all of them yes okay
because and then I can do my shallow
ones if it makes you feel better okay
fine I'll okay big red flags underbite I
can't I know it's shallow I know it's
shallow I'm being honest with you but if
you look like a cash register then we
can hide and we can I date now that's
shallow that's shallow okay and I'm
aware that it's shallow right but like
there's if I'm looking at you and I just
wanna go then I can't
I that's up but it's shallow and I
recognize it's shallow and it's stupid
but it's also the reality it's the
reality that if a girl
fell out that way about me now then that
would be her problem that's fine that's
a shallow thing I don't wear that but
for real though don't you hate it when
like those girls like they post pictures
Instagram not always like they're so
like I've seen someone with an underbite
sense of Steve last Stephen King movie
I've seen where are you finding these
girls I'm not finding them I'm just
saying me on potential red flag uh-huh
if we're even looking for incident
because yeah we shouldn't waste each
other's time okay you know we've in ways
yeah yeah yeah okay you know I'm sure
you girls will see things about me they
don't like ya and they won't do it you
can't stop stop no no you have great
teeth phenomenal teeth oh thank great
teeth but don't do that arrived here at
Howard's let's think about how not so if
I was did you just try to make it cute
[Laughter]
if you saw a photo of me on Instagram
and I was like subconscious fear of your
dick getting bitten no I think the fear
is that you're a bulldog your inbred so
that that's what that's how they do they
in freedom to have their faces look like
that that's how Bulldogs get that way
that's why I went berserk on Twitter
when the Bulldog won the dogs remember
cuz there was so much inbreeding yeah
they can't breathe they can't say die
they have heart it's like a whole thing
yeah yeah I think Ari had a funny joke
they're like they're the Jews of the dog
Kingdom like that they're just like
always like hard to breathe like all
these health problems and so what okay
Ella one okay you're very bird time that
you there
like about myself that for my whole life
and this is I mean I've always struggled
dating guys that weren't as tall as me I
think I think most girls have that I
think it's baked into your DNA it's like
a human nature thing and I makes me feel
like I'm emasculating you and I have to
make myself smaller and the whole thing
but don't you want to be the Alpha in a
relationship I don't I like to I'm an
alpha in my work I feel like in my
relationship I'd rather be a beta yeah
but you won't let yourself be a beta
oh there you you won't I know you won't
mm-hmm you can like cosplay it yeah like
let's be cute and hanging out in bed and
then you're like no I'm on that side the
difference between being an alpha and
just having strong boundaries and
knowing what you want that's Alpha IV
just described an alpha just self-aware
yeah that stuff where it's not people
are self-aware and very masculine traits
I never said it was masculine now at
alpha yeah I'm I'm yeah you just you
assume it's masculine mhm right so
you're having your prejudices for the
world very sexist right yeah we know
this about me yeah super sexist but um
yeah I don't know I think it depends I
think that you like taller guys you
should but yeah I mean I hated about
myself I don't like it but it's just I'm
trying to make you not feel like you
have to not be shallow
oh you're accommodating mine yeah I'm
taking care of you this is not up to us
we didn't make this decision we're wired
this time we're wired this way it's like
Who am I gonna go with in a fire it's
like that simple
what yeah it's like can you protect me
to fire if they have a Wallach to
protect you little realize we're in like
a cocoon
right yeah is there water on the other
side there is some water on the other
side oh you mean the water to fight
fires what do you mean some wait all the
water yeah okay I think I meant water
like to fight a fire
no because Topanga doesn't have water
they're on whatever was it not septic
what's the thing we have to bring water
up I can't remember but there is a big
there are helicopters on the top of the
hill I'm not talking about that clearly
now you mean like the ocean yes the
ocean we call it the ocean though
there's oscillation I call it the water
I love it when New Yorkers talk about
nature yeah cuz there there's these
blanket terms like the water like what
water
like here we have lots of iterations of
I saw a fucking emu outside planet I'm
on right now Oh better help aah
I mean it's so telling that this is one
of my sponsors and I'm very excited this
is one of my sponsors because this is a
company that will help you assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist that you
can start communicating with in under 24
hours not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is actual professional real
counselling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise in there
counselor network you can log into your
account anytime you can send a message
to a counselor you're gonna get
thoughtful responses you can schedule a
weekly video or phone sessions therapy
you got to do it
it's 2020 we're all suffering better
help thank you
commit it to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
some something I would do it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available love it better help wants you
to start living a happier life tada
visit better help.com slash Whitney
that's better help h ELP and join the
over 500,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional except there's
a special offer obviously for good for
you listeners get 10% off your first
month at better help calm slash quit
neck buffer I love this company Buffy
makes betting that is earth friendly and
cruelty free love it spent sleepless
nights worrying about the impact of the
betting industry that has on the
environment when I wasn't until now but
they decided to change it Buffy's
products are made using only sustainable
and recycled materials which makes them
as soft on the planet as they are on
your bed our latest product is called
the breeze it's a comforter made
entirely from a hundred percent
eucalyptus fiber to regulate temperature
and keep you cool and comfortable all
night long that's pretty genius actually
the breeze regulates temperature no more
night sweats I do that I'm disgusting in
the night and I guess I don't like wake
up at a nasty swamp get cozy with the
breeze without overheating the breeze is
made of eucalyptus fabric inside and out
it's softer than cotton naturally
soothes that beautiful skin of yours
it's earth friendly eucalyptus
uses ten times less water than cotton to
grow and it's fibres produced using
recyclable earth-friendly solvents you
know get a good night's sleep and have
some good karma yes please Add to Cart
for 20% off nope $20 off I don't know
that could be 20% you'd I'm not a math
elite for $20 off your Buffy comforter
visit Buffy dot CO CO and enter the code
Whitney that's $20 off your Buffy
comforter visit Buffy dot CE o and enter
the code Whitney I actually do like
nature yeah I do hey wait I just don't
have a lot of you know connection to it
yeah but and I do like animals yeah you
do we're back to our shallow thing okay
so we okay so another thing red flags I
think people really like this on the
packet okay I think girls need to hear
because a lot of times they can only
hear it from love a private Instagram
guys but you have to have a great
picture okay and a small thing okay
because at the end of the day we are
shallow right we want to see what we're
looking at where we tap in okay I'm
probably not gonna follow but there's
something about a private Instagram that
lets me know like she doesn't care about
people it's a stranger's validation hmm
you know and Who am I to say anything
about that I'm a comedian that's what I
do for a living that's a value but you
are oh you know that's clear it's not a
period but it's also not a side hustle
or something you're sneakily kind of
doing pretending you're not doing you're
very open about right we all are yeah
you know it pays our bills and I think
maybe that's why we admire people that
don't need that like so many of our
friends often are are these people at
least I find comedians we gravitate to
these people that really don't need
anything yeah we have enough to go
around we have enough of like a mulatto
that's a superpower you can just give
mm-hmm like whoa like how do you just
give your attention and give all these
things like we want to be able to do
that too you can just have conversations
in private with no one recording you'll
just hang out with your friends without
poor people we target Fresno at the
Comedy Store and I'll bag what are we
doing yeah I wasted like why are
supporting happens to me all the time
we're like is someone getting this can
someone document what's happening
otherwise what's the point it comes to
that you know I admire that a lot and I
also a guy told me recently a red flag
was your grid only being pictures of
yourself uh-huh like throw in a sunset
or uh yeah I don't
that as much I mean I often find that
girls that don't seek the validation
don't post only pictures of themselves
Yeah right so it goes hand in hand yeah
or they do but they're with friends and
there's like a purpose of the picture
and yeah I'll be honest I don't care if
you take pictures of your food I think
it's cool like you're going out to cool
restaurants yeah you enjoy cuisine like
yeah cool
smoothies yeah look I'm not gonna judge
that much no not that I like business
like I like you have a real job I I
think it's really cool if a girl has a
real job
yeah you have responsibilities yep you
have to fucking go to work Monday
through Friday you understand that
there's a boss and that boss tells you
to do shit yeah and it's difficult and
maybe you have people working under you
and you have to manage them and you
understand things about the real world
I also nice I also think it's important
that someone who's like you who tours
you need someone who crosses yes who's
grounded but also isn't home all day
cuz sometimes we're home all day and if
someone else is home all day too
you're just you're just get up on each
other when my girlfriend says I got to
take this this business meeting I can't
hang out tonight hot cuz it's hot it's
like whoa you have responsibilities and
there's something more important to me
in this moment I get that yeah please go
and then I don't feel as guilty and we
were speaking about this before but I
don't feel as guilty when I have to do
it I don't feel like I'm letting you
down yeah we both understand that this
is how the real world well that's right
we have I like able to pay for the
shephelah take you places I like people
to buy you things that because and that
takes sacrifice but like she's getting
her emotional needs met other ways
besides just you like you can't be the
focus also who's answering those needs
huh
is somebody else oh my god this is so
awkward but you're one of the most
self-aware self actualized honest like
not self delusional people I know so
this is what I want to ask you cool when
did you decide to call her your
girlfriend a lot of people were asking
what is a healthy amount of time she was
so patient with me and I and I told her
I said I mean that was probably part of
why you like her so much
yeah I said listen I am if I feel
pressure I run
like that if I feel pressure I run in
but I promise I won't waste your time I
stop wasting girls time maybe two or
three years ago uh-huh
I stopped just being a coward right
before I was a character didn't want to
hurt girls feelings so it kind of like
maybe string them along a little bit and
then I was dating a girl I think she was
in her 30s and I was like hey I want to
be honest with you I really I like you I
think we have chemistry I don't see this
going long-term and I don't want to
waste your time yeah I thought she was
gonna be so mad at me
she looked him she looked she was like
thank you so fucking much for not
wasting my goddamn time and eggs and
always literally - you're taking my
opportunity to have a biological child
don't wait for me cuz you can't you
don't think I can handle having my
feelings hurt and that's yes I cannot
stand salting that's right it's
insulting you're implying that I cannot
handle a basic emotions like I'm so
important I'll be okay yeah I'll get
over it even if it does hurt I'd rather
know now than in two years we could have
been friends when guys where to God we
could have been fucking friends I say
like I don't want to hurt their feelings
so you think it's gonna hurt less when
you do it in a year and have taken a
year of her life as well and ever since
soon as you can possibly do it so I
stopped boys and girls on I told her I
swear to God I won't waste a second of
your time if I see that it's not going
in that direction I will let you know
immediately when Garret when
girlfriend's a minor likely he's not
texting me back and I'm like he's doing
the kindest thing he could pot he's such
an asshole he's not an asshole he's
actually doing such a kind thing for you
right now hosting your time
yeah he's letting you hate him yeah
that's right it's the most humane thing
you can do yeah but yes I just I was
like listen let's just keep going we're
happy you're happy
and she was like listen I'll do it as
long as I'm happy if I'm not happy I'm
just gonna tell you and then I'll have
to move on like I have to take that risk
yeah I have to take that risk because I
know if this matures into what I think
it can be yeah it's gonna be great
here's what I'll say I also think part
of the reason you guys probably have
such a great relationship is that you
were able to have those uncomfortable
conversations in a mature way so it's
like having those conversations or the
exact reason you're gonna stay together
you know what fuck you fuck you and
being children about it you're right
you're right and you know it helps is
like girls that have like gone to
therapy from a young age
yeah cuz they're like aware of their
feelings right you just did your we're
feeling does me control it that's right
but you're at least like you're looking
for like convince one of your friends
that they having a feeling yes yes and
feelings are not facts like you're
wrapped up in a feeling right now this
is old you're not gonna feel like this
in two days don't take an action based
on what you're feeling right now you
have to just tolerate this discomfort
for a bit yeah well it's also she was
able to not play games with you I mean
that's the other thing it's like I have
so many girlfriends were just cool I'm
not gonna text him for three days and
I'm gonna post a photo myself having fun
at Coachella I'm like dude this is if he
responds to that it's not the guy you
want to be with exactly you know I mean
air city situation you want me to hang
out you because I want to hang out with
you right so you would rather have a
girl just be like I'm uncomfortable I'm
jealous I'm insecure then like play
games and pretend they're fine you know
it's really funny she'll be like hey I
miss you or something like that and if I
don't respond she'll do the you know you
could put two exclamation points Mike
holding down the text that's great I
love her it is true love when you can
send to texting around if you can send
two texts in a row and nothing like
that's it you overthink when you're
dating you've been with me when I'm
dated yeah around me I mean yeah I don't
know how many stories we could tell but
we definitely some funny ones I mean I
definitely outsource my decisions to
someone else because I know that stop
asking Neil exactly yeah even me
don't ask me oh right thing you're
fucking great advice don't ask Neil
that's really funny
that's really all I name he's got great
ideas and jokes a a a a a relationship
of course the joke is gonna be listen
the joke is gonna be perfect right
that's right to be a banger
[Laughter]
he's got a point
kids got a point you know joke is gonna
be perfect the joke about the failed
relationship is gonna be perfect if not
working out he's like give me five
minutes I know I just I think for me I
get so I can project I can turn anyone
into anything I want to turn them into
that's dangerous huh very I can buy that
I can basically I'm a writer first I can
basically write the version that's the
most convenient and I can selectively
delete certain things minimize certain
things rationalize certain readings for
example you know I haven't heard from in
three days you know it's not healthy to
talk every day it's actually this is so
much better because we're not I mean
this is I'll just turn anything into
saying how you become a great comic and
how you come horrible in relationships
is the ability justify anything that's
right there's nothing that you probably
can't justify and you probably do it as
an exercise just as a comic like take
the worse things it well it's also
devil's advocate 101 which is what we do
we do that's what we do we go actually
this is eugenics is a great idea is that
what the behind the white supremacy Oh
Rachel supremacy program like IQ based
on - eugenics program yeah it's like
only let smart white people breed with
each other
oh you specifically it's a breeding
isn't that what eugenics is I don't know
you guys might have to look it up I
don't I get this wrong and tonight
you're from the south huh but that is uh
that is really fascinating I think for
me I have a really hard time telling the
difference between compromising yeah
and deluding myself of like but you need
to compromise relationships take work of
when relationships take work philosophy
hits up against like martyring yourself
and being delusional like I have a hard
time telling the difference mean those
two things I have a hard time between
going like well you're kind of a judgy
bitch and like having high standards you
know like when do you lower your
standards that's something I like and
always struggle with yeah yeah I mean
because it's always like well you know
oh I'm just being judgmental like I will
blame myself for every possible
situation because I think when you have
been in therapy for a long time that is
the one sort of I mean for me drawback
maybe other people don't struggle with
it but I'll just go like oh well this is
that thing I do I'm judgmental so he's
fine I'm just being super judgmental you
know because I am so aware of sort of
the way my brain is wired I'll be like
well I'm just being a perfectionist you
know I'm just sabotaging myself for oh
that's just my intimacy issues like no
just don't take that guy that's how off
when you a date how often would you date
like how many guys would you date a
month I didn't date a lot you were
around I was I was dating when I was
like on a dating app I don't I can't
date a lot of guys I can't keep track of
things like I mean no no just you don't
believe in multi I don't believe in
multi tasking I really don't know I'm
just saying like would you go out in
like three dates a month with two dates
a month that's about right like so think
about dating like we would think about
standup like imagine we were trying to
make a special that was gonna be the
rest of our life and we were practicing
- yeah it really is practice isn't it I
mean practice just increases the amount
of people that you can hang out like
like there's certain people that you
just get along with yeah and I can hang
out you don't have to record a podcast
ya can be in the other room just talking
yeah we can have fun we just get along
yeah breezy we got along we really do
get a lot and I say crazy shit and then
every once in a while you're like you
have to stop talking like that stop
saying that things if you say something
and after that that I don't listen to
one of my favorite people like you we
get along I know but there's a couple
like to me like all my friends are male
comics for the most part I think a lot
of it is because I feel like comics can
disagree without getting sensitive or
taking it personally you know we always
know what the thought exercise it's like
we're just screwing around like I don't
really like we love each other or
anything you need it's sparring is what
it is well interesting because I always
thought for the longest time in
relationship epoch I'm bored I'm bored
it's like well all your friends are male
comics you hang out with statistically
the most interesting people male female
comics - don't do that comment section I
won't I shan't all my friends are
performers and entertainers like how can
I expect someone who's not
I don't want to date someone in the
business but if I do date someone in the
business they don't need to entertain
you I think they need to be entertained
by you yeah an entertainer yeah you know
like I mean as I've gotten to know my
girlfriend more and more I think I've
found these things about her that I find
funny and I'm so interested and like
invested in her life so yeah things
matter right but in the beginning it was
really nice to like have someone I
wanted to share with yeah and and I know
it sounds weird as a comic but I don't
really want to share with everybody
because I feel like maybe on some level
I'll be judged for my opinion or my
opinion might be nuanced in a way that
you might not respect that's or you
might just not understand it so when I
found someone that I found myself
organically wanting to share with yeah
really just wanting to share right right
right I was like oh maybe this is
something cool and I didn't I didn't
like try to make it a big deal it was
pretty cool because that's an I once I
think to me one starts something starts
feeling like an obligation it's over but
it but here's what I'll say instead of
me going like you know this I go well
come on this is relationships take work
and I'll just stay in things too long
because I'll just like well you're so
used to a constant and renovating the
animals that's it isn't it but why but
it's also a go-to there's a little bit
of ego in it because I equate the ending
of relationships with the vulnerability
and fear of starting a new one and I
just go it's probably less scary to stay
in this than to start something new
because you're afraid of those having a
meat peel like the new the only options
I have well then I have to start over
then I have to just like delete the
whole page right so to me it's like that
is what I weigh it up against but those
really aren't the only two options but
in my brain it gets very binary in black
and white where it's like where a lot of
people because I people sent in
relationship advice questions for us and
one of the main ones was like I'm 37 is
it better for me to just stay in this
thing that's kind of okay then starting
from scratch and by the time I really
meet someone it'll be two years I'll be
13 you know it's like it's cutting women
are constantly weighing that math why do
you think that people are so drawn to
you I mean just like you start this
podcast I don't know where it blows the
fuck up Shack start a podcast nobody
cared
do it there are a lot of lot of people
who are famous or started podcasts yeah
right but but people are drawn to you
right so what do you think it is about
that where did that come from
just curious the way more objective take
on it than I do I might be a bad game
about it but your view obviously thought
about this it's like I don't know I feel
like I love India that you're like why
do people like you know I like this one
I know hard for me to fathom that
someone want to listen to you talk no no
no no no I'm joking
no but I guess when I see like I feel
like it's very difficult for you to not
be yourself and I think that that in the
Internet age authenticity always wins
like cuts through the bullshit yeah like
mark and I were talking on the way over
here just about like when you have
options yeah authenticity always shines
through before we had no options that's
right that's right
it was whoever's on TVs are like who's
the most authentic like Frank Sinatra
that's right oh this guy seems pretty
real yeah yeah that feels awesome oh my
god he's upset at his wife right yeah
he's vulnerable he's sad he said right
and then it's like now that we actually
have people yeah being themselves
yeah yeah I think it's very difficult
for you to not be you and I think that
people it's refreshing I think we were
prefer authentic people we don't agree
with or like - inauthentic people said
are likeable mark goes this is my buddy
mark gangnams they're funny comic so he
goes he goes yeah I would rather an
authentic person that I didn't agree
with like morally or any of these other
things then an inauthentic pretty try to
fucking sell me something that's that
stop trying to show me that's also a
very primal thing is that you basically
feel safe you gravitate towards the
people you trust because if you lie to
me you lie about me I mean you feel
danger when people are for all of our
grandparents are racist that's right but
we love them because we trust them right
I know right it's real we like to know a
little yeah that's the girls I date
right I never met and my grandparents
they all died but but the point is like
we can love these people because it's
fucking true you know that I think
and I think yeah there's something about
that it's like you're giving your raw
self to somebody I wonder if that's hard
relationship makes them feel very close
to you you know that's the other thing
is I think they'd probably get close to
people quick and maybe that's tough I
have this thing where yes I think I do
tend to I think all comics get I think
all comics because we are in a situation
every night where we are with a bunch of
strangers that we need to make listen to
us I think what we have this ability to
kind of get hook into someone's energy
in a way and get it's very intimate I
mean it's a very intimate thing that we
do you know you have to make people know
you care about them right away I mean I
think whether it's chicken or an egg
where weather came comedians because we
were already good at that or whatever I
think we also have a very a skill to be
able to ascertain the room like we can
walk into a room ago this rooms weird
what's happening you can you could just
go this is a weird office party seven
strong yet party gone wrong like have
this sixth sense about energy we can
read a room the way that I think a lot
of people can't I got it I think from
growing up an alcoholic home where you
have to sort of always be able to read
what's going on and how how much does
someone had to drink and how dangerous
is situate you know I think we're just
good at that but sometimes I think
that's bad for relationships because I
think ignorance is bliss yeah in a lot
of ways you know how I think Chris Rock
said if ignorance is bliss being a comic
is the opposite of that mm-hmm because
we're hyper oh yeah everything yeah
right but it's like sometimes not
knowing that your significant other is
upset is actually the best thing because
they get over it you're like okay we're
good we have these like the way to close
the door what okay she mean the door
what was the door like no it was the
knob and no one why'd you lock the
bathroom yeah I'm not coming in like
it's just us here why is your phone
upside down yeah you know I do that my
cuz you can't you can't control your
past you can't like so if I get a text
but and it's not anything that I was
connected to in any yes way shape or
form
yep and this Texas popped up and now we
got a who's this let me say who that is
yeah do you want me to say what's about
why I just keep it with my heart
started beating I want this is my least
favorite this is the exact thing why
historically I haven't gotten out of
relationships because I don't want to
get into a new one because of this exact
moment what where you get that pit in
your stomach when a text comes up and
it's like who is that do you really want
me to tell you yeah your heart takes a
shit in your chest right and you're just
like you're embarrassed you don't want
to ask but you know it you have this
primal instinct to protect what is that
why I am I think whatever little bit
guys have fucked when I was four it
correct when I but I think that when
there's a lack of communication of when
you go pay if I I would now as an adult
go like hey could you like unfollow
certain people or could you like
whatever your I think it's something
that's still an open-ended thing I have
to go like are there any doors still
open and things I like that is it good
enough fun there are certain things you
sure there's a couple people that you
were dating when we met could you either
let them know or block them or I just
don't wanna get in a situation you know
what I mean yeah and I think you know I
think that uncomfortable conversation
which I think can be really bonding yeah
and really healthy can then prevent the
like who's you know I would say Tiffany
I'm sorry yeah but uh I think that
that's a I think that's an important
conversation to have before you get into
the ruin the fucking expensive sushi
night with one text yes the worst yes
because we get ya there if someone if I
think if a woman doesn't careful doesn't
open a door like you know how like
people like you know first I'll take our
guns then they'll take our wives mhm
you know like mm-hmm I think that I
think sometimes we think okay I'm an on
files on people and then next week she
can be like well why do you even need to
be on Instagram yeah why do you go to
the grocery store we get it delivered
right and now I'm just it was at the
grocery stores island with my girlfriend
right can I have some food it eats when
it's ready hit with her fucking
underbite grew out this looks like one
of those Bahamian pigs I think you'll
know if she's being unreasonable and if
she gives an inch take a mile
that's the fear we have right that's a
red flag on her end but I will give an
inch taken up take a mile that's how
you're built you're built to give an
inch and take mine yeah
I would imagine me opportunistic is
something that epigenetically we had to
inherit it's an opportunistic uh-huh
it's just woman yeah that's what you do
yeah maybe yeah
Oh holding hands now does that mean
we're something else that's I don't do
it I'm not like that
yes you are you just told me unfollow
people some PID think there's a thing
here I'll say if you're if there's I
think this is important elimination I
think that if you're following someone
that you were dating when we met if you
don't let them know that you're now in a
committed relationship
you're leaving vague oh you gotta if
they reach out to you you just gotta say
oh yeah yeah cuz here's my thing my
biggest fear in life is I bet you know
coyotes my biggest fear whether this is
healthy or not I'm just gonna admit what
it is I'm not proud of this my biggest
fear is embarrassment and my thing is
don't embarrass me so if people know
we're together and someone you were
dating is commenting miss you that's
embarrassing to me well they can always
comment you can't control what other
people do to you that's right that's
right that's not what if they feel like
the door is still open and they don't
know that you're in a committed
relationship yes it won't necessarily
deter them girls are haters if they're
gonna be districts of them if they're
gonna be disrespectful and not honor the
boundary I can't refuse a I set the
boundary and she didn't listen okay
that's my I have to deal with that yes
but if you didn't set the boundary the
first place how would she have known
that's fair you know that's computers
and then now I'm embarrassed I feel
embarrassed
yeah and that is for whatever reason my
biggest fear yeah I think I think that's
a pretty normal fear I think most people
just don't want to be embarrassed
mmm-hmm like obviously cheating is
messed up but like I was at I was doing
some whore party
corporate fucking shit and this the guy
CEOs wife was like I don't care what I
don't know doesn't hurt me she like said
she was like loud and boisterous like
nothing funny like almost cartoonish
like blonde lady yeah Florida and be a
minute yeah you have and I was like I
wonder if she's happier I wonder if in a
way she's controlling them hmm she's
saying don't embarrass me I'm giving you
a long leash motherfucker don't bring it
back home don't give it
take a mile boom now guys we might do
that mm-hmm right but there is something
to that I think that most yeah I don't
know maybe okay if a guy who would like
did shit well if you don't tell me how
would I know you know I I'd know someone
who has the philosophy that I actually
kind of appreciate it she goes if you
cheat on me in the next ten years like
they had just gotten married at like 30
if you cheat on me in the next ten years
you'll break my heart and you'll ruin my
life and after that don't tell me
because I wanted to eat you alive until
you get cancer just don't tell me cuz
then you have to live with it I will
sleep every night a friend of mine can
you say Jane Chu comic she's like a
really smart like podcaster journalists
okay yeah yeah it's interesting it's
hilarious she thinks who will eat us
alive like that's adorable like we're
gonna cheat more could I get my dick
shot capacity for empathy and
compunction in the first place if you're
the type of person who's capable of
feeling guilty I do know a lot of people
look that's shocking how easy that is to
get over we've heard this many times I'm
not the first to say like like marriage
was invented when the life expectancy
was thirty years old I know a lot of
people now who have been married 10 15
years now that's an accomplishment I
agree like if you get married yeah and
you make it 20 years and your kids are
out of the house and you guys realize
it's not for you anymore not a failure
look and by the way that's we here's
more than most marriages since you're
already MVP one percent you're already
in the top lumbers top one we've been
married 20 years and have kids I didn't
know it may accomplish oh you're the
fucking Michael Jordan of marriages
because I think we're in this like
perfectionist thing and I it's also like
a religious thing as well but I'm you
know I think where we perceive the
ending of a relationship as a failure
it's stupid yeah you've made it that far
yeah if you good game good game good
game and you can be friendly on you can
enjoy Charlie clear clearly there is
mutual love there you mean as long as
you respect the kids when people start
dividing the kids it's fun I'm actually
going to tell you something this is not
I mean obviously no one's gonna get
divorced because of something I say on a
podcast but I used to date someone who
had a kid his ex so his ex was like this
sort of brilliant meditation teacher her
new husband
you know taught the kids Spanish and
then I was in it like he had four
awesome parents that all had different
so when you get a divorce and handle it
like adults the kid now has four awesome
people like be in life if you can handle
it how's the kid maturely awesome
awesome yeah like awesome yeah that's
the key don't they say like the greatest
advantage of kid can have is not being
white or Asian or anything like that
it's two parents in a household hmm like
that's the thing that that's the thing
that basically covers all grounds and
parents don't have to be parents I was
raised by my aunts half the time like
it's just people know any kind of
authority figure who help it's to
parents um let me ask you something what
I want more red flags
yeah because a lot of people want to
know about red flags I think there's a
lot of women out there myself included
who for a long time only got
relationship advice from their
girlfriends and I love my girlfriend's
worst thing to do but they don't always
give a good fuck you never listen to a
woman about relationship in your life
they don't want to hurt your feelings if
I hear don't do it if I hear a girl give
another girl the advice maybe I just
think he might like you too much and
he's scared I think he's scared we are
we are really like obvious about how we
feel and you just judge our behavior and
usually that's it you will know mm-hmm
if we like you or not yeah there's value
face value always I always said every
value no matter how insecure you want
there's not a question yep okay if
you're not feeling it
in the beginning yeah later on you get
comfortable and like you get busy and
you might not talk for a day or
something and there's you just feel kind
of shitty but hopefully there's a
foundation there that you can rely on
but then it's on you to have faith
exactly and it's on you know on you to
just trust what's gonna happen is gonna
happen under percent but if you don't
feel like he likes you in the beginning
it's because he doesn't like you also if
you want a busy boss do we need to tell
girls this how many like every ten years
we just need to go he's not that into
you and then you forget it and then
another version is either and then Steve
Harvey's like hey this is how you got to
do it because he's no way of telling
girls he's not that into you huh and I
think it's because there's some ego with
women emanate there's arrogance there
was a girl at the show at the store the
other night and she came up to me
afterwards and she goes
she was like this just like hot Russian
need girl something and she comes up to
me afterwards and we're just kind of
taking Perry and she's like do you
handle your Instagram you can do
Instagram account and I was like I was I
guess you you don't have like assistant
and doing your Instagram I was like I
was like no why is yours oh because I DM
you understand why I mean look at me I
mean I you have a girl but look at me I
mean like I just in what world
it was completely so you're gay that's
my favor they all my girlfriends I
forgot that we got a chair with our
girlfriend okay we have to do it I'm
sorry babe I was gonna be gay so
whenever a guy rejects our my
girlfriend's all the girls like he you
know he might just be gay like don't it
just if a guy does speak with you and
Justin you know but I think that's a way
to self-preservation and staying to
waiters receive our egos you know but I
do think girls like that gets so much
attention that's why the game works
remember when that game was around
remember the game brows yes that works
so I think the whole point was insult
hot girls because they're never used to
being insulted reject hot girls because
they never get rejected and that's the
way to get him yeah but you know what I
hated about that oh gee I thought the
book was fascinating and it's just like
shows like another reason why nerds are
fucking ruining everything we're living
in Revenge of the Nerds that's correct
like the Nerds you end talking to girls
now you're ruined democracy marriage
ruins talking girls now you have to like
hurt a girl's feelings
fucking nerds yeah the Nerds shoot up
the school
yeah right it's all nerds it's not jocks
mm-hmm true to have the school's right
it's shooting up the schools and there
was another thing then there oh and
nerds are canceling people for yeah
yeah it's like now if the urge are
ruining the streets with the freaking
lime scooters kind of like this so I get
excited ER visits have gone up 33
percent
ah candid are you unhappy with your
smile or someone else I'm happy with
your smile your Diner feeling
self-conscious and photos why not make
this the year you straighten your teeth
with candid Canon delivers clear
aligners directly to you and straightens
your teeth for 65% less than braces oh I
did the clear braces when I was a kid I
wish I'd just done this instead ruined
my entire childhood
unlike braces candid clear aligners are
comfortable removable and totally in
visible it's like a magic trick you can
transform your smile without anyone
noticing a thang plus you never have to
set foot in a doctor's office or a
waiting room your treatment is
prescribed remotely by licensed
orthodontists and Canon delivers
everything you need right to your door
god I wish this shit was around when I
was a kid
unlike companies Canon only works with
orthodontist never general dentist this
means your treatment will be designed by
an expert in tooth with 20 years of
experience on average looking ahead to
wedding season special event want to get
your teeth in order you want to stop
having those scraggly wild-ass teeth
you're ready to take the first step
towards straight teeth for a limited
time you can get started with $75 off by
using the code Whitney and candid co.com
/ Whitney that's candid co.com / wit
neat use code Whitney for $75 off candid
cocom / Whitney code Whitney get your
teeth in order it's 20/20 whoo this is
the cutest ad read ever it's about
puppies whether you have a new pup or an
old friend and in bark breed and health
test is key to unlocking your dog's
unique breed mix and genetically
informed health needs so you can help
your puppy live its healthiest happiest
life and you know that's all I give a
crap about from breat rates to genetic
risk factors for health conditions
embark provides the resources to help
you and your vet best tailor care to
your dog specific needs you can finally
know your puppy dog because every year
millions of dogs are rescued from
shelters while we know and we love them
there's not a lot we know about them
right I've been through this many times
with an embark DNA test you'll finally
have the answer next time someone stops
you with oh oh my god how cute what kind
of dog is that and you're like
I don't know I think it's an alien are
you looking to know your dog's breed do
you want to know if your dog is at risk
for a genetic health condition you can
screen for 170 plus genetic health
conditions and help your vet provide the
best medical care for your dog because
that's truly all that matters in life as
far as I'm concerned I just sent mine
off and I'm waiting to get the results
back I cannot wait to see that my dog is
part Staffie part human
right now embark has an exclusive offer
you cannot get any where else go to
embark vet comm now use promo code
Cummings to save 15% off your dog DNA
test kit visit embark vet comm use promo
code Cummings
to save but yes so it's like I don't
know oh yes so the thing that I hated
about that book was the idea about
making a girl feel bad yeah is you must
not think that you were enough and
enough or as good as her I think that's
what the book was for it was for people
that were like year 5 she's a 10 right
so why don't you make yourself a 10 yeah
guys have this amazing luck that we're
born into the ability to choose our
number right yeah sure you've probably
done a joke about this yeah the idea
that like I can get wealthy if I ugly
get success yeah I can get great yeah I
can be the best at darts yeah and
there'll be a girl who really values you
can go to a 10 with a boat with with a
bolt hmm the tier 2 plus boat equals 10
nerd math exactly Hunter is that so yeah
there's this we have the ability to do
it and I and my thing has always been
like with a girl is if I talk to you a
long enough yeah I don't need to shit on
you I don't need to like make you hurt
your feelings yeah you will realize yeah
my value right okay now I'm gonna bust
your balls because we're human beings
right but it's not what the attendant
persons the tenant purpose of blowing
your self-esteem so you can fall the
sudden your I feel really low right I'm
not trolling making out like this little
yeah I hated that aspect of it I just
thought it was so insecure yeah like
there's nothing
sure about it yeah that's what it was it
was also like do you really want to be
in a relationship that is predicated on
lies and manipulations and it's the kind
of thing you'll get I mean it really is
just like how to sleep on it some in a
couple of times look I don't want to
forget this because also yes we're
coming back to that but you also said
that like in terms of we have to tell
women every 10 years he's just not that
and you I do think though every 10 years
the way that people express that throw
that into you change and different like
things I mean dating now is totally
different than it was 10 years ago
there's totally new ways to be rejected
and to be found and you know is it that
different maybe is anything that
different I think it gets well because
you go like he didn't text me back but
he posted on social okay she didn't call
me you know I mean huh oh you're more
aware of our behavior that's right it's
more it's more confusing I think if
you're gonna be confused if you're the
kind of person that does get confused
which is all of us right I think it's
it's harder to ascertain your look well
he didn't call me he's just he's busy
he's working but he just post on social
and uploaded on Facebook so you know
what what it's you should be able to
tell you're getting affected quicker
actually though and you know what it
actually makes you know you talked about
being bored in relationships like my
girl said this to me once I thought it
was really interesting she's like I was
texting her so much today I'll tell you
later and I was like you just saw me now
she's like no but I like to have
something to talk to you about when
we're like together I was like dude that
is smart because if I'm already looking
all your stories mm-hmm and then we're
texting all day by the time we hang out
we there's nothing less for us to talk
about I'm gonna save some fucking shit
I'm gonna think you're boring which
you're not I just did too much I was
excited all day I spoke to you all good
I got the spoilers from your Instagram
yeah I just want to wait and watch the
movie I want to watch the game when I
get home don't tell me what happens and
she forgot it and I was like oh that's
good so we saved some yeah save the
story there was a book that Elizabeth
Gilbert wrote called committed and she
was talking about what really marriage
means in other countries and stuff and
she does this there's a chapter on
intimacy and how if we tell if we
basically connect emotionally too much
to people during the day by the time we
get to our partner we don't need to do
it anymore and then it's almost like
having had sex all right like you don't
need to do it a certain number amount
connected so there's certain things that
happen to you that you need to hold for
your partner so if you get like really
big news like you don't call all your
guy friends first and then by the time
you get home you're like I got the thing
and she's like well I don't know and
then you're not sharing that it's like
keeping the doors and the windows closed
is what she calls it
that's interest you got to hold it you
got to hold it that's for your partner
and because then what happens is then
you're emotionally investing in other
people and then you start to have
emotional Affairs and then you're like
well they don't understand me well you
didn't tell you they want to feel part
of it my girl does say that often you
gotta save it for her I wanna know I
want a fee I might not be there with you
but I want you to tell me about it so I
could feel like I'm still a part of it
it's like if we're gonna have sex later
don't jerk off I don't jerk off ever I
jerked off once recently uh-huh but that
is rare
I only never jerked this new no how long
has this gone on few years really yeah
and it's not something I like I give
advice to I just don't have the craziest
sex ride so it's like I gotta save it up
for my girl yeah you know I mean she's
young she's 24 yeah she wants a fuck all
the time and it's like I'm 36 I don't
need to fuck all the time yeah so if I'm
whacking off right and having sex it's
too much yeah that's too much too much I
find a lot of guys that I know now are
either intentionally trying to stop
jerking off and watch porn I mean this
is I haven't watched porn in forever
really yeah I'm not against porn I was
training on pornhub for your titties
yeah the day that I was trending on
pornhub that morning I got like 30 texts
from my guy friends like oh you're
trending on porn and I'm like dude I got
that I thought you did all on purpose to
be honestly I thought it was like genius
marketing that's like yo Rachel coming
out drop the titties on Instagram that's
a really dark this is how it is it is a
genius so I would have done it that is
pretty genius
I'm about here's one you got it create
but if you have you don't mean my bug I
don't have built our corporation I gotta
find waves so my role is myself exactly
so that's a genius thing I got some
titties that are gonna come out if I was
gonna plan that myself I would have
picked a better photo I'll tell you that
right well I haven't seen I remember
what it was like a see-through
no it was I was in a tub and I'm like
holding a sponge it's ridiculous it was
from making it was a few weren't they
there's a couple naked photos of me on
the Internet where my head is will you
google them just Google Whitney Cummings
naked and there's photos number one I
thought you made up your last name Bill
Byrne I were talking about that there
people like why would I choose that
named I thought you made it and why
because it was like sexual or something
and it was the fucking 90s that's a
nightmare
so see there's ones that are
photoshopped but it's not really me like
that's not me you know I mean these are
not me all right we're gonna get to dogs
I promise but I won't a lot of people
want to know guys include a great first
date idea great first date idea I don't
ask anyone I've everyone event on I
haven't asked anyone relationship advice
you're the only that's a great first
date idea not dinner drinks really you
had rent dinners too much of an
investment and you can't really talk
while you're eating and shit that's
great don't ever you can get food like
with the drinks like little shit but you
really want to have salad in your
fucking teeth you're worried about what
you're gonna order and now you're all
full and know just have some drinks
conversation that's it it's a real
question I have to be able to talk and
that can't be loud I want to talk to you
okay if it's too loud what are we doing
that's right that's a I'm trying to meet
then I think you're annoying I just
think you're allowed yelling nag that's
what it's just like you have to yell
over corner table that's right we can't
be across from each other hmm we have to
be like this I'm here you really yeah
knees touch every once in a while and
then like what time 7:00 know who what
tense oh my god 10:00 p.m. your first
date well you're New York yeah we stay
up a little later 9 after 9 has to be
able to me if a guy said first day 10
o'clock I would say like this is a booty
call yeah
treat it like a booty call that's what
it is first date you are making it not a
booty call that's your job my job is to
try to fuck is to try to not fuck my job
is to make you want to come back to my
apartment right and fuck your job is to
go I'm gonna go back to his apartment
maybe but I'm not gonna fuck if I like
him
so I think when it come back if you like
me go no or don't if you want your
makeup girls always say girls like
sleep with it depends on what you want
if you want to date this person
long-term you cannot hook up with them I
don't think on the first couple days
yeah just give head for a while oh you
don't give head I don't I don't I don't
that I hate that word why I hate that I
hate pussy panties and give hat those
are my those are my three least favorite
if blowjobs I know it shouldn't be a job
didn't feel like a job yeah it shouldn't
yeah I know I don't never do that I
would never do that till after sex you
would have sex before head to me that is
way more vulnerable long necks because
you're like I can't see them there's
that is that is crazy but uh women
because you can't see them like it's
just it's more vulnerable to me it's way
more vulnerable to do that then have sex
with somebody where you're like equally
I cannot tell you how different my
dating experience yeah yeah we've I'm
I'm very prudish would that be the word
yeah I'm dating people i if head is
funny like once I had a lick my dick at
a bar but like it was funny but it was
on a date yeah and it was just like a
fun day yeah I thought you wouldn't do
that B's to vulnerable yeah I don't I
wouldn't like to sing at a bar now it
was it was funny no it's out you know
I'd be crazy but I think I never was
like a one-night stand person I never
like hooked up hey come on we didn't
even hook up that night really yeah what
hide out and stuff like that but she's
like no I'm not respect for a girl she
hooks up with you on the first night no
never your respect is based on who you
are respect is based on like how much we
have in common interest like my respect
isn't based on like how quick I get to
your pussy yeah like I've dated girls
for years that I fucked in the first
night huh I'm but maybe I'm different
with that but like huh if you're only
qualifying factor to bang a relationship
is that you didn't fuck me the first
night hmm like what kind of standards do
I have yeah yeah why you gonna fucking
vows because I don't like anything else
about her but you can't say she has
willpower you can say that
who do you like willpower though I think
it's I think yeah I do I really do yeah
it is sexy
because it's also something like ooh I
threw everything at ya and it didn't
work yeah
now I trust her not getting tricked by
some dude yeah oh that's a great point
you're just no moving forward I know
you're safe you control yourself but
there's also something hot about a girl
who's like I don't care about like
socially constructed standards I'm gonna
do what I want and I'm gonna enjoy it
those girls will also not be wooed by a
guy that's right they're fucking Kay
right to not be some guys manip we're
constantly trying to see yes yes anyone
the way of protecting it is a girl going
no I just do it I want and I want to be
with you no and the other version is I
can tell anybody no I can not have sex
for six months forever in a row like woo
me yeah and you're like I feel safe with
everything's done on her terms
that's basically it who pays I pay for
everything what happens if a girl tries
to split it we don't split it ever we
don't split it that's so hot but I think
women are confused no they're not
they're very not confused really yeah we
don't split it if a girl insists on
split again you don't you can't exist
[Laughter]
like a man from the for it is you know
what it's also so weirdly so modern time
ever
frightening ever my girl isn't pay for
anything ever listen she pays for things
without me knowing
uh-huh that is that hope I love that so
much you know like if we're going on
vacation like oh how give her the credit
card and everything like that you go
book a plus character yeah that is your
book
she'll book the flights or something
like that okay what are you doing she's
like just let me know let me bubble
that's the class act but you know what
I've never once never once gone to
dinner gotten a coffee mm-hmm bottle of
water at the gym without her be like
thank you never once do say never
entitled never one time and it's like
I'm not doing it for that yeah I'm doing
because it's nice to know she I mean I
make more money yeah III made more money
uh-huh why would I put financial
pressure in you when I don't have to
yeah I wanted I wanted the last thing
that you don't worry about is financial
pressure yeah but um you know saw this
that's my job to pay for it yeah no that
says how
ha this is how the world is you know but
a thank you or gratitude it's just so
dope yeah I think it gets tricky because
I think that sometimes you know a lot of
women I know we're stuck in between this
like the man wants to pay because of the
same reason you're saying but also
there's this like gold-digger frenzy
that everyone's terrified that women are
gold digger so I think we're kind of
like well I want to split it just so you
don't think I'm a gold digger who's
afraid that yeah you can always do the
thing where you put it out mm-hmm that
never gets old I think it doesn't become
an issue until the relationships over
and the guys who can spend so much money
on her dude I maybe it's that I've spent
tons of money on girls and yeah work out
what it is yeah this just happens
something I mean yeah I'm sure you've
bought cars before you're like right you
thought that car was gonna be with you
cars I don't buy cars oh really
buying cars is so crazy to me even the
Tesla doesn't it D depreciate as soon as
it's driven off the lot have you seen
humans I don't buy cars I only lease
cars I'm getting that new Tesla though
are you which one oh the stupid the big
the Fred Flintstone car nothing was
funnier to me than that press conference
when the guy threw the rocket that's a
purpose do you think we're talking about
are we ah you mother it's like the
easiest part of that whole car is making
glass that doesn't break and that's so
true like he's made a spaceship you
think you can't make glass it doesn't
break it says by your angio this is how
you know it's fake when he throw I
wanted to come out if it was if it was
that's the other thing
Ilan come on can't control he would not
have released something if it was
embarrassing now the easiest part right
when the guy threw the metal thing at
the glass he didn't try to get out the
way as if it was gonna bounce back which
it would if we all know the laws of
physics if that glass doesn't break it
bounces back with the equal and opposite
force right and it bounces right back
into his fucking face that guy chucked
it at it didn't duck and follow-through
boom hey make the windows break
why because everybody's going to talk
about the windows breaking but then
they're gonna every other part of the
car the window is the easiest thing that
beats the window if the car didn't
fucking go on electricity that'd be a
problem
blowing my mind Thank You titties that
is there was just one she has bad breath
he won't look at that he's like I see
what you doing blowing my mind you did
it in the bathtub so they know it wasn't
the robot now the robot would
malfunction I was almost gonna release
the email but it's a lot of like legal
shit okay I feel like we got through a
lot we need to get through the animal
thing
these have been going on long the bill
burr was I think two and a half out yeah
the best but any other red flags like
quick red flags if you can think of any
talk about your ex yeah I get I don't
really care about why you'd even talk
about that just yeah I think that
there's nothing that's gonna be for
every person right oh you're asking what
I think is a red flag but that's not
gonna be for someone else you know
what's the biggest age difference that
is sustainable age gap I think my only
thing is you have to have some like
musical interests in common I dated
someone who's older than me and I just
was like I don't know any of these songs
I don't want to listen to Robert Plant I
don't know these people
you know I don't have to listen to clear
clean ins Clearwater Revival like I'm
good
I don't know for me it's just like do we
get along or not yeah it's simple as
that
my girls younger than me of course but
maybe she doesn't relate as much to like
the people her age maybe she is kind of
like older yeah you know she's older
brothers and like is a for me that's it
what's the opposite of red flag white
flag great light green light yeah so the
green light I don't know if that's it
but like I love girls that have brothers
especially older brothers because a
little bit less sensitive eye things and
I only less sensitive they've had to win
over men aha there's sexuality right and
it's a very important distinction
interesting a girl that has to if she
wants to hang out with her brother and
her brother's friends those friends
can't fucker interesting you got to be
interesting
funny and neuter yourself in a way
uh-huh you have the neuter stuff but you
also gotta come with it yeah like oh
we're gonna snap on you because you're
we're not trying to fuck you so guess
what you're gonna get made fun of yeah
can you deal with it what do you say
back my brother's friends used to put me
in trash cans I'm telling you every girl
older younger older I'm every girl with
older brothers yeah every single girl
tip out every but most girls are older
brother's way better taking jokes
funnier
yeah and way more like pragmatic yeah
but also I think that for me hang out
male comics and my brothers and shit
you also like kind of a fly on the wall
and you hear them talk in a certain way
where you know they don't really mean
you know what I mean it's just talking
shit you don't say you're not like what
do you mean by that you're like oh
they're just kind of talking shit you
know fucking shit yeah so it's like I'm
night I don't rolls off you know I also
think is your next special called not
all not all you say it like would you
like all women not all and I think I
would I have no problem saying all but I
have no problem every single one of you
okay and there was a couple questions
people want to know where you must like
to go on vacation for some reason cuz
you travel so much it has to be like a
cultural experience okay I don't care
about going to the beach sand
I was Russia Russia was this really
really it was the most interesting place
that I've ever been to in like the
Western world Wow
it was like physically fascinating you
know it's the idea architecture early
for Russia when the you know of Soviet
Union was running shit was it kind of
was in line with communism where each
person was no more important than an ant
right we were all part of this bigger
thing you're fogging machine in the way
that they tried to sell this was not
only through like you know cinema and
all these other things right but also
through the architecture the streets
they're like where the cars go are
massive we're talking about four lanes
each way on a regular street Wow and the
buildings are massive like you know New
York they go up high that's right but
this is wide and tall and you walk down
the streets you're like wow I'm
insignificant I'm tiny make you feel
small it was a new way to design
humanity if it wanted be very
interesting and when you're there you
fucking feel it and the people were
really cool they loved comedy like I you
know kilter they've ripped off not
ripped off but like they did their
version of kill Tony they did their
version of roast battle yeah they got
comics pictures all over the clubs that
Louise still they're prominently uh-huh
you know to be like this so then on
Wi-Fi it just it's fascinating to see
them kind of like fall in love with
stand-up yeah
and I'm seeing this happen all around
the world because of YouTube they were
they found American stand-up recreated
their scenes in these places and it's
just this beautiful thing and I wanted
to be there because like it was like I
feel almost a responsibility just
because I've been big on on YouTube and
like YouTube has been great for me and
it's like I have in a weird way a
responsibility to like nurture these
scene yeah I can go out there and I can
do some some shows and those comics
they're go I'll fuck it's a real thing
we could we can talk to these people
yeah should continue doing this yeah
especially in countries that aren't big
on like letting people express
themselves that is like so key and
what's more interesting than hearing a
Russian can be like that's why it's
important yeah
because how you tell the truth in a
place where you can't yes the joke and
there's even more tension it's just so
funny I also want to see all that comedy
because it's like you want to know what
real cancel culture is when they kill
you think you're being oppressed because
you can't say that word you want to say
on a college campus next week try comedy
in Korea that's it yeah though they're
coming out of fucking Hong Kong the next
great comics wow I don't know if they
are but I'm saying that they have a
situation that's right for it my bad you
know like the best are idols all came
from times of censorship that's why I
don't hate the censorship we're in now
yes it breeds great well then see that's
the thing I'm vegetarian talking about
this but I don't think what canceled
culture people don't realize is you're
just making the people you're trying to
cancel funnier and you're creating a
tension where more things are taboo yes
and it just makes gives us more things
to talk about every one of these
journalists and wants to talk to me and
I and I never do any of these interviews
aspire these magazines but like everyone
is like you know how do you feel being a
comedian cancel culture and I'm like
great there's it's not real it's a very
thousand people well it is but like
people can lose TV shows and that kind
of shit
I don't care about that yeah but for me
it's great I care about and up and
that's it yes if people are trying to be
on like an ABC Family that's right right
and do stand-up the way I look at it is
like you're not really doubling down
I'll stand up no you you watch your
priority that's Adams your side check if
that's exactly so I know what why it is
for me yes so I love this error like you
said the most tension I love saying
something they're just making more
things taboo they're just openness more
things to talk about that's it although
I did I think I might have talked about
this
maybe when girl was here but that there
was a comedian on stage who was doing a
joke about fat chicks recently I'll tell
you who afterwards and someone the
audience just went can you stop wait
like she just was like can you please
stop like and he it didn't go well and
then it was hard to get back on the
rails did he say can you stop eating it
be easy just to stop huh I don't think
she was even fat I think it was a
typical here's my here's my I thought
about I just was like dude I don't think
it was cuz you were time up I think it's
just like a familiar territory
you know just hacky I think she was just
writing like fast for could we just fast
for like we've seen this just tap out
like if people don't realize what is the
opposite of love it's not hate its
apathy mm-hmm right that's a comedian
the most what do we hate the most right
it's not a crowd booing booing I'm
eliciting a reaction yeah yeah if I have
a reaction
yes negative yeah all I need to do is
tweak this the worst thing is nothing
the worst thing is nothing so when you
go can you move on yeah second that
someone does that to me in the audience
I'm like oh I'm close it's there I'm
close it's loving there right there
right there yeah and if you just give me
yeah an intense reaction can be
alkalized into comedy sir right away oh
this hair tension release care amen I
made you care yeah if someone just
doesn't give a shit there's nothing you
can do
I will abandon the joke people think
that we're like these fucking Crusaders
yeah we will not tell unfunny jokes
that's right that's right you're a good
comic they're not gonna keep telling
unfunny joke
you can try to work at work at working
and it's not there you okay that's right
yeah this is not fucking social justice
right we're not fucking taking a knee
and I think that's what's really
important is a lot of people to
understand a lot of time when you're
seeing a comedian maybe not it like a
theater near you actually I work out new
shit in theaters like you might see a
comedian doing an iteration of a joke
where it's at its embryonic stages and
it's not done yet you're seeing good you
should be so lucky to see sort of a you
know undercooked joke like yeah young
comedians in the gym working it out
maybe that's why those people are so
pro-abortion too because they're like
yeah it's eight months but get rid of it
we believe in late term canceled jokes
[Laughter]
[Music]
hair on its head you did yeah how well
you don't you don't do you have any
dreams about that you gotta do I find
how delicious your twin was you care so
much about animals and this guy I just
killed a human
I know I know baby a baby I didn't want
a twin I wouldn't have liked it yeah I
think that yeah you didn't want to share
space I like your vacation answer one of
you lost cry you can skip this if you
want no I don't mind I like talking
about crying crying is important healthy
I cry at movies oh yeah I find that guys
do I dated a guy that you know that
cried during uh the movie fences and the
funny thing to me about guys and in
crime movies is that like the dams break
for like all the crying they aren't
allowed to cry because it's not socially
acceptable for men and there's like like
sobbing like Field of Dreams the guys
will cry for two days after they
Remember the Titans middle seat on a
plane i snot cried middle CM middle seat
now
I've cried I wear hoodies important part
of that I wear hoodies yeah on planes in
case I'm gonna watch a movie I can hide
I'm flying back from Hong Kong
my buddy recommended this movie Alix
media does other video stuff yeah yeah
he recommend this movie called 5 feet I
suppose they have a movie marked 5 feet
apart and it's like I you know there's
people who got like coughing and
something wrong with their long what is
it called whooping cough yeah whooping
no what is it
Oh emphysema no no cystic fibrosis okay
right
that's cystic fibrosis movie yeah isn't
that in your lungs or something I think
yes they're contagious so I guess you
can only call five feet okay they
basically have to be five feet away from
each other but it's a love story and all
this thing and like he he has one that
like really kills you and she falls into
a lake and he pulls her out he has to do
CPR and he's like oh my god but also he
can't do CPR cuz they can't take deep
breaths he gives his last breath and I'm
fucking weeping blame coming back from
Hong Kong not the most emotional people
the change no no no and I am weeping
weeping this movie awful movie it's not
even that good at movie feeds it's five
feet apart
although here's what I will say what
this is how screwed up our businesses I
know you are interested in stuff like
this and we were talking about movies
earlier this is how screwed up the movie
businesses when I made an independent
movie which andrew was in and stole a
scene of I had a good time so good you
let me do anything you're my favorite
no directing has been good since ma I
like my thing is hire the best person
and then leave them alone let them go
that's my thing
don't hire the best person then
micromanage them into something that's
what every search every time I get hired
to do something I get they're like do
you even want me like what's the point
who the hard part was hired by hiring
the hardest part then leave them alone
let them establish chemistry like you
and Blake Griffin had such amazing
chemistry like dude dude getting
involved at all would have just made
things worse you know I think my anyway
we can go on and on but anyway so what
you make me do you make a tiny movie you
know like you're like okay this is you
know you want people to see it you want
be a big deal whatever I remember
getting a call that was from the
producer it said oh my god we have the
best news ever for the movie and I'm
like what like film felt like Spirit
Awards or Sundance what is it
we just got bought by planes dude this
is how movies get the motional I seen ya
do Delta bought your movie was on Delta
for six months people have no choice
what's a watch it in a fucking coffin
dude it's so hard to get on planes
because you have to check so many boxes
yeah like you have to hit a couple
quadrants you have to be broad appealing
you have to be funny you can't be too
offensive like it's really hard to get
on planes so many people would
screenshot it's the most exposure yeah
yeah like I mean better than ight so I
was like and it's advertising right it's
like you see the movie on the plane you
watch it you're like what is that movie
yeah and you're watching it alone so you
don't have any time for someone to go
fuck this like I did it like you're just
kind of doing and it's such an intimate
thing love a plane movie yeah so it's
like that was sort of love a plane movie
by the plane movie also when we watched
five feet apart is me mark and Alex
mm-hmm
and we all synced our start by playing
together so that we could all cry in
unis come on did we did do it was so we
would sink it so it we would all cry in
unison I was the only one yeah I
sometimes wonderful wait looking sorry
you fucking pussy please talk about
crying with your friends
I can't believe you don't like what was
the word Bobby
head is a weird word for you head is
just so we wrote no I looked at it I
sometimes look at my screen to make sure
that you know I'm so paranoid about you
know when people get that white line
around their lips yes I am so paranoid I
have it so I went to look in and then it
started talking to you okay so that I
feel like guys many times have like
super cathartic experiences by watching
sad movies like Rudy I've watched guys
watch Rudy and they have to get up and
leave the room and they don't come back
for like four hours never watch Rudy was
really okay ever that's for me now that
YouTube exists yeah I'll just watch the
compilation of the ten saddest parts of
movies Sally and I'll just get it out I
like getting it out like just cleanse
your son release like I feel very
sensitive right yeah are you of course
you can't do this if you're not sense
how do you feel you have to feel like
what's happening in the world you feel
what people care about
you have to feel what's going on in path
that you have to I'm there yeah I don't
allow it to affect me yeah like I it
comes in yeah and that doesn't affect
yeah right I try try not to so I have to
feel everything that's going on in the
world yeah so I can be writing and
thinking and being creative about the
things that they need to hear about they
don't even realize yeah you know I'm
saying you know I got into the zeitgeist
yes you have to be empathic you really
have to be an elephant I don't let it
out that's right so I need to everyone's
well yeah yeah you're want your
conductor you go hard up merch you
fucking kill emerged we added I love
yours done it really did a drop this is
crazy
yeah thank you see calming start to do
this is this the one that I saw the
faster night yeah the three day drop but
we had like a six-month like random like
marketing we didn't even plan on it
being marketing we're at having fun with
these fashion videos we're just trying
to find a way to like push I love this
shirt the fashion shirt yeah I guess I
want that shirt done Ben 10 you want
anything I want to know where you heard
that song that you started using so
we're in a air B&B right and stuff like
we would I'll tell you so we're in an
air B&B right yeah and for like a month
in a row we just randomly only got black
air BnB s-- uh-huh so we're calling them
air R&B
and it was just randomly these my
families yeah I was like mark are you
doing this on purpose like what the fuck
and we're in there and I'm like we have
these shirts and I'm like do we have to
find a way to like let people know the
shirts are there but also just have like
fun like everything should be fun yes
right like yeah comedians yes yes yes
yes it's got to be fun gotta go back to
being fucking silly
we're silly it's fun so I go this what
we're gonna do
mark get up eh eh a runway song like one
of these techno songs and Alex and I are
gonna put on the shirts and we're gonna
do a runway and then pose you can see
the first one yeah and and then just go
and he just randomly picked that you
pick one song and we're like nah that's
not it and the second song is this one
now it's by this this person named Naomi
smalls
right and she's one of the drag queens
from Oprah's not Oprah's what's a
RuPaul's yeah so and she's one of the
drag queens from RuPaul's Drag Race
right which I've later learned learned
about this show well this show is
fascinating Oh drag race is the best but
I was asking one of my friends about
this Matteo Lane desert car and I said
can you explain why this show is so is
so good explain explain to me I haven't
even seen it he goes you know what it is
it's one of the first shows that wasn't
made that it's trying to explain gay
people to straight people it literally
is just made for us
yeah it's got all of our slang all the
things that we talked about yeah and
it's so nice to like see a show where
we're not dude we're not like dressing
someone straight yeah yeah yeah yeah
fixing us look how are you we're useful
we could be in your home yes we we did
this this song we're playing it on every
single one and people love this song yes
if you go to if you go to Naomi smalls
YouTube page the comments are Shultz
brought me here and here I reach out
turn DM doesn't respond I have Matteo
talk to her about her she's aware of it
does
respond I'm getting ghosted by Naomi's
Naomi we just want you to be part of it
fashion video with us it would be
legendary well she won't she won't she
won't hit me back she's busy
nothing do not do the email I guess I
got an email I don't know this one the
email feature I bet we can get a
response you probably maybe not me and
what do you want it does I just want her
to be in one I think it'd be really cool
like come do uh well we did he have yeah
like you know we whatever way we were on
the same city he's a drag queen he's a
drag queen that's he or she they usually
don't I can say either whenever I'm okay
I just everybody she every buddy no
because he says y'all dude somebody why
do they call why they call people that
South so big it is it's like y'all is
the most inclusive term that's so funny
I like the idea of like you know when
people identify their gender on the
bottom the email like he him y'all
alright what I got to piss I know I got
to go tell me everything we need to know
just Graham and it's I what is it that
Andrew Schultz is yours and Rochelle
it's websites the in shows he's the
killer he's Keller Gus p.m. just go go
check out my YouTube you took that
concise dangerous trail to be like stand
up and if you like it watch done if you
don't that's cool too
now we're gonna go argue about animals
[Music]